[Música]
hace 8 años tuve cataratas
las cataratas son una enfermedad en los
ojos que te nubla en la mirada que no te
dejan ver las cosas como son
sientes que tienes como telarañas en los
ojos la cosa es que después de un rato
te acostumbras con un poco de
incomodidad sigues viviendo con la
mirada nublada te parece normal
pero en algún momento pasa algo se
agravan y sientes que no puedes seguir
así sientes que tienes que operarte
después de eso
uno no solamente mira mejor con más
colores y con más texturas sino que
curiosamente uno siente que oye y hasta
piensa con más claridad
yo pienso que pasa algo parecido en el
mundo vamos por la vida con nuestras
cataratas y las telarañas son nuestros
sesgos inconscientes que no nos permiten
ver la realidad cómo es que nos nublan
la mirada los ojos inconscientes que a
su vez generan los roles para diferentes
grupos como los roles de género son las
telarañas con las que vamos caminando
pero déjenme hablarles un poquito de los
sesgos inconscientes los seres humanos
en la evolución hemos desarrollado la
capacidad de reconocer patrones esto nos
permite navegar eficientemente las
enormes cantidades de información que
recibimos
y esos patrones los hemos adquirido con
la crianza la educación los libros las
películas los amigos en general con
todas nuestras experiencias esos
patrones no generan sesgos creemos que
la mayoría de las veces son positivos
como por ejemplo cuando vamos caminando
por una calle y escuchamos el sonido de
un bus acelerando automáticamente sin
pensar nos alejamos de la pista para
eliminar la menor posibilidad de ser
atropellados
sin pensar
el problema es que a veces tenemos estos
sesgos inconscientes respecto de grupos
y ahí los efectos pueden ser terribles
como cuando pensamos que las mujeres no
son buenas en matemáticas porque un
hombre de origen afro solo puede tener
éxito en los deportes
los sesgos de género más los roles hacen
que pensemos que las mujeres son de
cierta manera que son buenas para unas
cosas que son malas para otras y a
partir de eso tomamos decisiones que
tienen costos personales y sociales muy
grandes estos roles bastan en todos los
ámbitos en el ámbito académico en el
ámbito social en el ámbito laboral
tenemos por ejemplo los estudios que
lleva adelante pasarín van allí ella era
la directora del departamento de
psicología de harvard y después ha
estado trabajando en el departamento de
admisiones tratando de eliminar los
sesgos inconscientes de género y de
clase en los procesos de admisiones y
ella nos estuvo asesorando en la
institución en la que yo trabajo para
lidiar con nuestros propios sesgos de
género
ella nos reto a llevar procesos de
selección de personal anónimos
los candidatos no tendrían su nombre
sino un número que se eliminaría de su
currículum toda referencia que pudiera
revelar su género solo con eso la
cantidad de mujeres que pasó a la etapa
de entrevista se incrementó muchísimo
para nosotros fue un shock pensar que
nuestros sesgos de género y asignación
de roles había hecho que tuviéramos un
trato diferenciado entre hombres y
mujeres perjudicando a las mujeres
lo que pasó en mi organización no es un
caso aislado es simplemente el reflejo
de lo que pasa en la sociedad
salimos un poquito de los roles de
género todos sabemos que la mujer tiene
el rol de cuidado y cuidado de los niños
el cuidado de los enfermos el cuidado de
los adultos mayores de cualquier
familiar en discapacidad el cuidado de
la casa con todo lo que eso implica lo
que tal vez nos haga no sabemos es que
al menos en el caso del perú todo ese
tiempo que requiere el cuidado cae en 73
por ciento del tiempo en las mujeres
esto nos lo dice la oit de cada diez
horas siete horas y media la ponen las
mujeres es claro que hay un desbalance
pero también es como si siguiéramos con
nuestras cataratas nos nublan un poquito
la mirada es un poco incómodo pero ahí
seguimos vemos las cosas normales pero
igual que con mis cataratas que siento
que llega un momento en que la situación
es insostenible y tenemos que actuar yo
creo que la pandemia es justamente eso
porque la pandemia ha desnudado los
frágiles que han sido los avances en
términos de igualdad y de equidad sí es
cierto que se había avanzado mucho en
esto pero también es verdad que se ha
retrocedido muchísimo tal vez décadas de
ese avance a causa de la pandemia
veamos un poco de sus números de la
pandemia
la primera línea de defensa son los
médicos y las enfermeras de ese grupo
del 70% son mujeres
hago un pequeño paréntesis decimos
médicos y enfermeras en femenino
justamente asociando a que el cuidado y
la asistencia femenina cierro mi
paréntesis
entonces decía 70% del grupo que está en
la primera línea de defensa son mujeres
pero además
la pandemia ha traído consigo el
confinamiento y el confinamiento esta
debacle económica y la debacle económica
ha traído quiebras pero sobre todo
despidos
la consultora mckinsey nos dice que las
posibilidades de que una mujer piedra su
empleo en función de la pandemia es el
doble a que lo haga el hombre y en el
perú
la estadística de la encuesta de empleo
nos dice que estamos casi en ese mismo
ratio casi el doble de empleos perdidos
por las mujeres por qué pasa eso
porque las mujeres son más baratas de
ser despedidas es más barato despedir a
una mujer que a un hombre y eso porque
las mujeres tienen en promedio menos
tiempo una empresa abro otro paréntesis
eso pasa porque las mujeres a lo largo
de su carrera dejan el empleo para hacer
temas de cuidado el cuidado de la
familia la maternidad
además pasa porque las mujeres son
mayoría en esos segmentos de empleo que
están más golpeados
pensemos turismo tenemos restaurantes
hoteles
pero una vez que la mujer perdió su
empleo es mucho más difícil para ella
poder recuperarlo porque porque las
mujeres están súper ocupadas en la
pandemia son las que apoyan las de la
escuela tienen que cuidar a más adultos
mayores que hoy día están más recluidos
que nunca y con menos posibilidades de
ayuda también porque es más difícil que
realizar las labores del hogar en medio
de la pandemia entonces las mujeres
simplemente no tienen la cantidad de
horas que se requiere para poder
regresar al empleo
antes de la pandemia con las mujeres no
decía que entre 2019 2021 27 por ciento
de mujeres dejaría en la pobreza después
de la pandemia y él mismo una mujer nos
dice que eso no ha ocurrido sino todo lo
contrario 9,1 por ciento de mujeres
entraron en pobreza
esas son 47 millones más de mujeres
pobres en el mundo producto de la
pandemia
pero hoy no acaban las malas noticias
la violencia doméstica también aumentó
por el confinamiento por la frustración
porque hay menos posibilidad de auxilio
porque hay menos posibilidad de denuncia
aunque es cierto que los países
organizaron sistemas de llamadas de
emergencia que han sido muy utilizados y
eso también ha sido el caso en el perú
queda claro pues que la mujer viene
sufriendo los costos de la pandemia de
manera desproporcionada
significa eso que este es un problema de
mujeres mi respuesta contundente es no
porque esto no sólo afecta a las mujeres
afecta a todos afecta a las familias
pensemos por ejemplo
en una mujer de un hogar humilde que
pierde su empleo con eso el bienestar de
todas las familias afectan mucho más a
que si el padre fuera estuviera perdido
el empleo porque la madre toma mucho
mejores decisiones familiares en
términos de educación salud y seguridad
alimentaria eso no me lo inventado yo
eso lo sabemos las personas que
trabajamos en el desarrollo después de
décadas de trabajar con programas de
transferencias monetarias condicionadas
pero no sólo por eso también porque uno
de cada cinco hogares por lo menos en el
perú tiene sólo un jefe de hogar y ese
es la mujer entonces la mujer pierde su
empleo pierde su sustento toda la
familia
queda claro pues que el costo de la
pandemia lo viene sufriendo
desproporcionadamente las mujeres por
eso es tan importante actuar ya en
generar mecanismos políticas públicas
que detengan esa situación ahora y
también es importantísimo comenzar a
pensar la reactivación con una
perspectiva que corrija esto y que
permita a las mujeres ser parte de las
oportunidades que se abren
argentina en nuestra región ya viene
trabajando en eso
canadá tal vez más ambiciosamente está
hablando de un plan de reactivación con
lentes feministas para cuidar de la
justicia y de la inclusión
necesitamos corregir lo que ha ocurrido
estoy segura que cada vez somos más
mujeres y hombres convencidos de la
necesidad de un piso parejo para hombres
y mujeres
si nos sensibilizamos a ello vamos a
poder limpiarnos de esas cataratas y
también comenzar a eliminar esas
barreras que impiden la equidad
decía pues que tenemos que hacer
políticas públicas que corrijan lo que
ha ocurrido y que nos permitan
aprovechar las oportunidades que vienen
una cosa que ha traído la pandemia una
cosa positiva es la transformación
digital esta se ha acelerado
el desafío es ver cómo están las mujeres
en este mundo y la verdad es que estamos
sub representadas sub representadas en
el mundo de la inteligencia artificial
sub representadas en el mundo del
análisis de datos sus representadas en
la ciberseguridad
esto lo sabemos que es el 24 por ciento
eso lo sabemos a partir de las
estadísticas del consejo de gerente de
informática a nivel global el c
entonces si no hacemos algo estos
empleos no van a estar allí para las
mujeres en igual proporción que para los
hombres y ese es un tren que las mujeres
jóvenes no se pueden perder y como ese
tren hay otros y es por eso tan
importante que tengamos políticas
públicas que se hagan cargo de esto y
eso tiene que ocurrir ya que eso no
solamente lo más justo eso también es lo
más conveniente
el foro económico mundial antes de la
pandemia nos decía que se incorporaba
más mujeres al mercado laboral en igual
proporción que los hombres la economía
en el año 2025 habría crecido en 26% 26
por ciento
es muchísimo sólo pensemos que cuando el
perú cree de secrecía muy dinámicamente
inicios decirlo crecía un poco más de 5%
por año
no hay ningún factor que afecte
positivamente el crecimiento más que
incorporar agresivamente a las mujeres
al mercado laboral al crédito al empleo
y el mismo foro económico mundial nos
dice ahora después de la pandemia que si
comenzamos a trabajar en esto ahora en
lugar de esperar el año 2024 para el año
2030 el producto bruto del mundo habría
crecido en 7.6 trillones de dólares 7
puntos 6 trillones de dólares
es difícil entender este número como un
equivalente y eso es como que para el
año 2030 hubiera en el mundo 30 perú más
o dos alemanias 30 perú por incorporar
agresivamente a las mujeres a la
economía y al empleo
en mis interacciones estos meses con
autoridades de la región
cada vez que sale el tema de las brechas
de género que han ocurrido a partir de
la pandemia con más con mayor o menor
sutileza con más énfasis o no me hacen
saber que este no es el momento
realmente para hablar de la perspectiva
de género
yo pienso que al contrario si queremos
tener el crecimiento más dinámico
necesitamos incorporar a más mujeres
yo veo las cataratas en sus ojos yo
siento que tenemos que operar las
necesitamos comenzar a trabajar los dos
temas la equidad y la economía de manera
junta necesitamos trabajar la economía y
también la felicidad porque la felicidad
de las mujeres y de las familias se
afectan
se afecta un poco las mujeres no tienen
carreras tan exitosas de la que sentirse
orgullosas se afectan porque los hombres
se pierden de cuidar a sus niños cuando
son pequeños se afecta porque las niñas
no tienen modelos a quienes seguir
y porque el costo de trabajar cocinar
cuidar la casa y verse siempre perfecto
a gota a la más fuerte y más valiente
tenemos que trabajar en eso ya tenemos
que operar nos esas cataratas ya y
acepte que lo que se trabaja en la
economía también se trabaja en de
equidad ver los dos temas juntos ahora
es cuando
[Música]